Harare is an opposition stronghold but
the governing Zone repair party has its
supporters in the capital too two weeks
before his re-election bid president
Emerson's strategy to Take Back Control
of urban councils which are mostly run
by the opposition is to remind voters of
problems such as no running water from
Council taps or inadequate refuse
collection in towns
will not stand by and elect our people
suffer at the ends of this clueless
opposition LED councils we must kick
them out only 20 of August
we must
democratically and the Constitutional
kick them out of the councils
and the weapon we use to keep to kick
out these failures
is your fault
monanga was main opponent opposition
neither Nelson Chamisa is also on the
campaign Trail he leads the citizens
Coalition for change party Triple C he
says his supporters are being victimized
there is no freedom of speech in
Zimbabwe and that it's time for change
[Music]
are you ready for the new president
are you ready for a new life
human rights wanted to say incidents of
political violence are concerning
last week an opposition supporter was
killed at a campaign rally in the
capital the police are investigating
what happened and several people are in
custody was wearing some Suburbans
because what would happen after the vote
if the election results
the economy is the main concern for
voters Zimbabwe has one of the highest
inflation rates in the world all the
presidential candidates say they have
solutions to the country's economic
difficulties voters will have their say
on August the 23rd
haramatasa Al Jazeera Harare